[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh tim legler espn
nba analyst kind enough to join us from
milwaukee
uh tim where does giannis's performance
last night
and in this series ranked to you all
time
the performance itself last night is one
of the greatest i've ever seen and i
don't care
you know if we're putting in the context
dan of nba playoffs nba finals i don't
care
period just in terms of any player in
any game
i think about how many athletes get the
rare opportunity
to play the greatest game of their lives
in the most significant moment
of their careers that's what he put
together last night very few
guys can say those two things in the
same sentence
right yeah a lot of guys can get to the
promised land and win a championship
and it might not be their best night a
lot of guys
have incredible games in of course the
regular season in their careers but it's
not in this moment
biggest stage brightest lights and he
had the greatest game of his career
it was one of the most awesome displays
i've ever seen a combining force with
finesse
because he this is a guy that obviously
struggles at the line
you know to do that from the fat line
had a step back 18-footer in there had a
three-pointer in there had a push shot
like a one-handed push shot from the
foul line
at a critical time in the game combined
with
all of that power at the rim and just
overwhelming the suns it was just an
absolutely awesome display
it's it's it's almost hard to describe
accurately how great he played last
night
i actually think he's underrated tim
because we kept looking at what he
didn't do
instead of what he does do and okay he
didn't make his free throws
but he didn't he did make his free
throws last night i don't like him
handling the ball bringing it up the
floor
i don't like him taking jumpers i wanted
him down on the low post because
he was unstoppable there boy this
is this is certainly a uh a message to
the rest of the nba
god forbid if he does hit all of his
free throws and he does
develop some kind of outside shot um i
mean that
that's scary that's a scary scary
proposition for this
and he does want to get greater as you
know playing in the uh
in the league certain guys get to a
certain level and they're fine with that
it doesn't feel like at age 26 he's
gonna go you know what
this is the kind of player who i am it
just doesn't seem like that's in his dna
i completely agree and he's he's he's
the kind of star player i was thinking
about
it you know i played with a lot of stars
over the course of my career hall of
fame
players and you know this is the kind of
guy as a star player that you want to
play with as a teammate because
there's going to be zero complacency and
that's what you love about him which is
what you're describing
and i think a way to sum it up with him
you know he doesn't want a great moment
this is a great moment he doesn't want a
great moment he wants all-time greatness
and that's going to differentiate him
and so
it's impossible not to root for this guy
it just is he's he's everything you
could want
an athlete to be he he the way he goes
about his business
the kind of person he is the kind of guy
he is to be around every day
upbeat positive energetic hardest worker
on the team so he sets the tone there
um you know constantly giving praise to
those around him despite the fact that
last night he
literally lifted an entire team and
franchised the city
on his back i mean if you want to talk
about a guy putting something on their
back we use that phrase
all the time last night that should be
what you see if you look that term up
and you google that is giannis out to
the kubo last night because he had very
little help offensively
from his star players bobby portis was
great without bobby portis last night
they don't win the game
but the other guys middleton was decent
late he had a couple of big moments late
in the game but for the most part
holiday and middleton are not good
he scores half their points practically
um so
he's everything you could want in a star
player in in the face of a franchise
he epitomizes i think what it should be
about
to feel the weight and responsibility to
do this for a franchise that drafted you
if you reach this level of greatness
and that's what he took on when he
signed that contract and decided to stay
and i think it's phenomenal for the
league that a guy can prove you can do
it this way too it's a different
script than what these guys follow now
yeah i think the key now
is will free agents want to go to
milwaukee they did make the trade for
drew holiday
they gave up a lot of draft picks for
him feels like a young nucleus
is there i also wondered about this tim
and maybe
i'm seeing something different i thought
that the series
felt like it was shifting when drew
holliday started to pick up chris paul
three-quarters court
it changed the tempo made paul work a
little bit harder
um and and to me i know we can talk
about the greek freak with the block
or the alley-oop but that was a real
subtle move
by the bucks mike buttonholzer that i
thought changed
chris paul a little bit and changed the
phoenix suns offensively am i
am i reading into it too much no you're
dead spot on and after the first game
and you know not even after the first
game about middle the second quarter of
the first game
i'm taking notes getting ready to go on
after and i'm saying this has to be the
worst
defensive game plan i've seen the team
come up with to defend pick and roll
in a long time you know you had three
days four days whatever was the suns
to prepare for the buck i mean the bucks
to prepare for the suns
you have one of the best mid-range
players in the history of the game of
chris paul
and you're gonna decide that you want to
either switch all ball screens
or put your big guy defending the screen
15 feet off the screen so he can come
off
unimpeded get to an 18-foot area of the
floor for a lean back jump shot which
his bread and butter play
and you'll let him have it the entire
game and i'm after the game i mean
everybody was in on that obviously and
they're just pounding
the the box and pounding their
preparation it made no sense
give them credit they made the
adjustment and they said
if drew holliday's on the floor he is
going to target chris paul and and so
not only picking them up 85 feet dan
every time
chris paul brought it up after he made
basket or a dead ball and chris paul is
bringing it up
it was holiday 75 of the time pj tucker
was doing it
jeff teague would come in and even do it
a little bit and these guys were turning
him bumping him
just draining his power meter that's
what it did and it took away his
aggressiveness in the half court but the
other thing they did
in addition to picking them up when jr
holiday was getting screened
starting in game two he wasn't handing
him off to whoever came up
on that screen he was continuing to
pursue chris paul
and eventually with just enough help so
he couldn't get off a mid-range jump
shot from your big when he would pick
the ball up jew holiday then was back on
his shoulder
making sure he wasn't going to be a
factor later in the possession
so not only the the you know the wear
and tear of all those possessions of
turning a guy
bumping him in a 36 year old guard
facing full court pressure which we
don't see in the nba ever nowadays
to do that but also to say you know drew
you're gonna blanket this guy it's like
it's like a
cover corner right and i remember i'm a
washington football team fan and we
brought in josh norman a few years ago
and i was so excited because we needed
to cover corner and then the very first
game i'm at the game
and the star ride receiver for the other
team you know goes in motion and josh
norman doesn't move from his side
of the field and and i proceeded to
watch this guy torch the other corner
for a huge day and go what's the point
of having josh norman
if he's not going to cover this guy the
entire time that's what drew holiday
became
starting in game two it was chris paul
is going to be targeted i am the guy to
do it
and and that to me that subtle change
completely changed the complexion of
this series and chris paul
until last night basically was a
non-factor offensively if
every nba player were healthy during the
post season
who would have won the championship
brooklyn okay brooklyn i i just don't
know how anybody was supposed to deal
with that level of firepower
to me that collection of durant harden
and kyrie irving
that is the single greatest trio of raw
offensive talent
ever assembled in this league i do not
know
how you were supposed to have the
personnel that the depth
the scheme to be able to defend all that
you're talking about three guys that can
beat you on every platform offensively
they can beat you
they can make plays off the dribble they
can beat you from deep on a ball screen
they can
beat you with the mid-range they're all
great finishers
what are you supposed to do with that
much talent
and you can always have that steve nash
can always have two of the elite
offensive players in the game on the
court at the same time and
and start and finish every half
with all three of those guys it's just
too much for anybody to deal with so it
was
it was going to be the nets that they
were going to win this and and look
it is a narrative dan you're not we're
not taking anything away from the bucks
but you can't dismiss the fact that the
nets broke down the lakers broke down
the clippers broke down
even a team like denver with a healthy
jamal murray after they picked up
aaron gordon that's a team that
legitimately could have made it to the
nba
finals so you can't dismiss all of the
injuries but give the bucks credit they
took advantage of what the landscape
looked like this year and they broke
through and
the confidence they have going forward
could mean this is the start of a great
run because we don't know if the nets
are going to stay healthy next year
those guys barely have played together
they have a lot to prove
and the milwaukee bucks are going to
carry themselves like champions now they
believe they can get through any
pressure situation based on the way they
navigated this postseason
what should the suns do with chris paul
and what should chris paul do with the
suns
well he's got a player option for 44
million so i know he's not going
anywhere
that's going to be he probably signed
that in the locker room last night if
he's smart
to get make sure he gets that 44 million
uh so he's not going anywhere i think
what what they have to be honest about
look at their team
just like we talked about the bucks just
now the same thing with the suns look at
the landscape in the west
with the with the kauai going down
anthony davis
going down jamal murray going down um
you know this was
the perfect storm for the suns to make
this kind of run
this year but they're they're a guy away
they need an all-star
caliber wing with some length that can
get his own shot because
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
through the western conference next year
if those teams stay healthy
with what you have so chris paul has a
significant role in this team i do
believe that
but they can't go forward thinking oh
we've got these two great guards and
that's going to be enough because we
went to the finals last year
assuming that okay ayton gets a little
bit better bridges gets a little bit
better
cam johnson gets a little bit better the
problem is the ceiling on those three
players
is is significant it is significantly
lower
than what we're talking about with these
other teams and their second and third
best players it just is
mikael bridges and cam johnson are
really nice players they're never going
to have the kind of handle
that you're going to need to be a 20 to
25 point scorer in this league on the
wing
you're just not and those are the
players that lead teams to championships
so
they they're a guy away but chris paul
will have a significant role
on that team and certainly he's going to
be untradeable if they decided to go in
a different route
and thinking yeah this could be a guy to
get somebody else over the hump
at 44 million i don't know how how you
do that
who should trade for uh damian lillard
um i'd love to see damian lillard in
philadelphia
if you pair damian lillard with joel
embiid
and the shooting that they have there
with seth curry
this that to me is the team then that
can get into the mix in the east and
truly challenge now
there's a lot of talk about that
obviously that would that would that
would
include ben simmons leaving town which i
think everybody in philadelphia
is ready for and they want to see happen
he's an elite level
athlete and talent but he is missing a
gene
that you need and his fear of failure
was so evident last year in the playoffs
i don't know how you go forward with ben
simmons i just
certain markets dan are never going to
forget
and forgive and it's unrelenting and
he's in one of those markets i've spent
37 years living there
he's in one of those markets which is
another point actually about
at the cooper i was thinking about today
how blessed and lucky he is to be in a
place that has
shown him unconditional love forgiveness
and support
despite the fact that he was a two-time
mvp with the number one seed in the
league and didn't make it to the finals
if he is in a northeast corridor city
there's a very good chance the media
coverage the fan base coverage what he's
hearing every day
turns so negative and sour if you feel
like you have not lived up to
expectations in a given year
he probably doesn't make the same
decision he made to stay
the fact that he's in that type of
situation
allowed him to feel the love even though
they came up short and he was doing
everything he could to get him there
that was a big factor in this i think
that's going to also be the situation
with ben simmons and why he's going to
have to leave
the first sign of him turning down a
shot
near the rim next season whether it's
game one game two
they're gonna start and they're never
gonna stop uh until
until he's out so i think they have to
make a move if they can do something
with portland
and give enough ben simmons picks and
maybe throw into tyrese maxi or somebody
like that
maybe that's enough to get lillard and
little embiid is that would be a very
phenomenal
combination to watch uh it was fun uh
legs thanks for your contributions to
the show
not only uh today but throughout the
season we appreciate it as always
always love coming on dan i'll talk to
you thank you legs that's uh tim legler
espn nba analyst uh former
nba vet